- Sauerkraut!
No, that's cheating.
- You're totally...
- You're saying it with your eyes!
You're saying it with your eyes!
(gagging)
I mean, you're already going to win this,
just by being a nice white girl.
- You know, many happy
roommate relationships
have been torn asunder
over fridge politics.
Meet Dani and Auri.
Childhood friends and now
adults living together,
who can't agree when to throw
food out in their fridge.
Either way, they're going to settle it,
today on Debatable Throwdown.
(intense music)
- We've been living together
for about two years now,
and I mean, it's lovely, really.
- We've been friends
since we were nine, so..
- That is nice.
- Food waste is a big problem in America.
Dani doesn't throw out her food
and then it rots in the fridge
and then she gets mad at me
because I hold it up to her
and be like hey do you
want to throw this out?
- I think that is just
like some privileged shit.
She's just trying to show me,
she's like what at what you're wasting.
Look at your mom in
Puerto Rico had nothing
and you're wasting this food.
- You're totally...
- You're saying it with your eyes,
you're saying it with
your eyes and your bangs.
- She's crazy.
She's crazy.
- You see that?
That's a ho-ass move.
- Every time I go grocery
shopping, I try to go put food
in the fridge, and there's no room
because there's all
this dirty food wasted.
If you're sharing a fridge
you should be considerate
and not leave a lot of
food waste, that you make
your roommate clean up.
- I buy the majority of the groceries.
(hissing sound)
- No, I don't even eat there.
- You bitch, yes you do.
And I make delicious meals
and you fucking eat them.
- You always talk about delicious meals..
- And I make them in the thing.
I will take pictures.
- Okay, that happens maybe once a month.
But it's like this myth that keeps being
blown up and purported.
- You are lying to the people of America.
- I wasn't eating...
- Oh, my fucking god.
And they will believe her, too.
That's great.
- Alright, I think that's plenty.
I think it's abundantly
clear that neither of you
are gonna budge on this issue.
So it's time to settle
it with a throwdown.
(theme music)
- What the?
- Hang on.
Behold, the throwdown zone.
(intense music)
Come along.
Now what you see before you...
- I'm scared.
- Is going to settle your
issue once and for all.
You'll notice the challenge fridge,
and over here a wide
array of food that you
might find in a fridge.
Some of these excellent
ingredients for a smoothie.
Others not so much.
You will have 30 seconds
to throw the items of your
choosing into your designated hole.
Dani, you'll have the top hole.
Auri, you'll have the bottom hole.
(snorts)
After 30 seconds the food
that lands in your hole
will be placed into a
smoothie that your opponent
will have to drink.
So what they have to drink is up to you.
Whoever finishes their smoothie first,
or drinks the most of it, will
be the winner of this debate.
Is there anything on this
table that particularly
appalls either of you.
- [Dani] Everything.
- Alright, let's put
the time on the clock.
And throwdown.
(laughter)
- [Auri] That was my
strategy because I don't want
to eat hot Cheetos.
- I'm gonna get you some
peanut butter and spinach.
- [Auri] I don't think
I can throw this far.
- Spam!
We're not getting... ugh!
Some sardines.
- [Auri] Oh my god.
I like sardines.
- Oh, it went in!
You're eating sardines.
- I love sardines.
I really enjoy them.
- And a GMO Pop Tart.
(bell sound)
Oh!
- [Auri] I should have
joined little league.
- [Dani] Apple!
I'm just good at this
because I'm Puerto Rican.
No, that's cheating!
Peanut butter.
Yogurt.
Sauerkraut.
All the sauerkraut.
- [Host] 3, 2, 1.
(bell sounds)
Okay, alright, that's plenty.
Time's up.
That's enough.
How do we feel that went?
- I object to all the food waste.
- Well, it looks like
you got plenty in there,
but let's be honest, the
things you are fighting over
the most are leftovers, so let's
do a 30 second bonus round.
- What?
- Bring in the leftovers.
- [Auri] Oh, god.
- [Dani] Oh, shit.
- [Host] Get the pizza in there.
Beautiful.
We've got some leftover Chinese food.
- They're nice and cold.
- We've got some nice nuggets,
we've got french fries,
we've got pizza, we're got sushi.
Let's put the time on the clock.
And throwdown.
- [Auri] Oh my god.
Damn it!
(laughter)
- You can't do that.
(giggle)
- You have a whole pizza in there.
- [Host] 3, 2, 1.
(bell sounds)
- You put the glass in?
You trying to kill me?
- I feel there was some flagrant disregard
of the rules here.
We are going to make
these beautiful smoothies.
And you two are going to
go to head-to-head in a
smoothie chug... chug-off?
- [Dani] Ew.
- Let's see what we ended up with here.
In the top fridge,
so this is going to be for Ouri.
- It's Auri.
- Now that's a beautiful smoothie.
- Oh, wow, gorgeous.
Oh, fuck.
- [Host] I'm going to hand this to you.
(laughter)
Here are your smoothie ingredients.
- Oh, my god.
(laughter)
- Dani's smoothie.
- That's like spinach
and pizza, I love that.
- [Auri] There's also a nice
helping of sardines in there.
- You fuck.
You did not do that.
(inspiring classical music)
(squish sound)
(playful music)
- Yeah, I have a gag reflex problem.
- Yeah, maybe you should
have thought of that
before you didn't throw your food away.
- Maybe you should shut the fuck up, Auri.
- Smells like peanut
butter and ranch dressing.
I want to smell yours.
Want to smell mine?
- No.
- Oh, yours just smells
like a green juice.
Mine is so much worse.
- No, it doesn't.
Ugh.
Oh, I can't.
(gagging)
- I got two sips, though.
- Oh my god, it tastes
like the devil's diarrhea.
It was terrible.
- It tasted like ranch
dressing and fecal matter.
- I don't want to look at it.
No.
- It's alright, it's okay.
The aftertaste is way bad.
- Well, great work.
You got a whole two gulps in,
and you just started gagging immediately.
(laughter)
Auri, take it away.
- Auri was right and I was wrong.
- Auri was right, I was wrong.
- We'll take it.
- I will be more vigilant
about the food in the fridge
that is rotten and needs to be thrown out.
- I will be more vigilant
about the food in the fridge
that is rotten and needs to be thrown out.
- Well, congratulations.
I'm glad I could help
you settle this matter.
That's been Debatable Throwdown.
- Cool.
(playful music)
I'll tell you, for a
video about food waste,
we sure didn't get that message across.
Still good though.